yesterday white supremacist
hitler-loving neo-nazis wearing make
america great again hats
and toting fully semi-automatic
double-barreled ar-47 assault rifles
descended on the virginia state house to
take over the government
and establish a prussian ethno state in
the fevered imagination
of the mainstream media in reality law
abiding gun owners of all colors and
backgrounds showed up on lobby day
to defend their constitutionally
protected civil rights
and there was no violence whatsoever and
they cleaned up after themselves when
they
left we will examine how virginia gun
owners shot down the leftist narrative
on our second amendment rights then aoc
has
the single dumbest conversation i've
ever heard
with leftist journalist tony heasy
coates president trump's impeachment
trial kicks off
and some great news for the pro-life
cause ahead of the march for life
all that and more i'm michael knowles
and this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to yesterday was a very
very
scary day for the mainstream media it
was not a scary day for
anybody else it was a totally normal day
and there was a wonderful demonstration
for some of our basic civil rights
that took place in virginia but for the
mainstream media it was a terrifying day
presumably because their fellow
americans were demonstrating on behalf
of their own civil rights
there was a pro-second amendment
rally yesterday in virginia thousands
and thousands of people
were there the left told us politicians
on the left
elected federal politicians and state
politicians and the mainstream media
told us that the rally was going to
include white supremacists
and domestic terrorists we needed a
state of emergency in virginia
they were going to come to the
commonwealth of virginia
and cause violence and mayhem here is a
quick montage put together
by newsbusters of the terror ahead
of this second amendment rally right now
thousands of gun rights activists
white nationalists militia groups all
swarming the virginia state capitol
there are a lot of people nervous about
what's going to happen authorities in
richmond are on a high alert it could be
intense state
polarization what may happen in virginia
several hate groups supposedly some
white nationalists white nationalists
white nationalists white nationalists
white nationalist groups white
supremacists white supremacists white
supremacist
white extremists this entire rally
stands
in in opposition to the meaning of this
day virginia on the edge how concerned
are you that
there might be some people in this crowd
that may want to get violent there's
certainly a lot of concern here raising
fears of a dangerous confrontation it
could be violence
there's real concern there about what
the intention is behind this
a lot of concern about the potential for
violence
that sparked violence tensions high in
virginia may cause violence there north
and clearly trying to avoid another
charlottesville
in charlottesville could see a repeat of
what we saw in 2017 in charlottesville
similar
to what we saw in charlottesville
worrying about a repeat of
charlottesville
horrible 2017 charlottesville disaster
you look at what happened in
charlottesville
the two sides clashed in charlottesville
men walked through the capitol in
virginia
carrying weapons of war many
demonstrators
are in fact heavily armed heavily
heavily armed heavily armed look at the
gear
what is this all about militia groups
armed militia
these militia groups far-right militias
militias militia groups
far-right extremists extremists
extremists that is not
a fraction of the hysterical coverage
that we saw
before this rally in virginia that is
not that is not a small fraction of it
okay and they told us it's attentions
high alert obviously cnn was on high
alert obviously there were a lot of
tensions
in the newsrooms over at the new york
times and cnn
but how did the rally actually turn out
we cut back
to a very disappointed cnn look those
threats
which caused the governor to call for a
state of emergency
have simply not emerged the police very
clear in saying that they have not had
a single arrest during this rally those
threats those threats came from you you
did it you me the mainstream media you
created the tension
you tried to provoke a violent incident
in charlottesville and it didn't work
because
the people who were demonstrating were
not neo-nazis they were not white
supremacists
they were not what i don't white
extremists that was a that's a new term
i hadn't heard that one before how do
you how can you be extremely white
like are scandinavian is that that makes
you extremely white
they're all of these new terms to try to
gin up in particular
racial division and racial hatred and it
just didn't happen
none of it happened because generally
speaking
second amendment advocates are
very concerned with obeying the law i
mean
they're basing their their gun rights
enthusiasm
on the constitution right that's where
we get our right to keep and bear arms
cnn had an incredible headline the cnn
headline read
virginia gun rights rally concludes
peacefully
despite earlier fears of extremist
violence that's just the headline whose
fears
their fears those are the only people
who had
the fears they go on in the story a
large gun rights rally in virginia's
state capitol
unfolded peacefully monday despite
earlier fears of the kind of violence
that took place in nearby
charlottesville
three years ago we'll hold it there
what on earth would link a lobby day
demonstration in favor of a basic
civil right to
charlottesville charlottesville an event
that took place as they say
three years ago completely unrelated
completely different groups completely
different point
even the rosiest take of the
charlottesville event
was that they were there or some people
were there to protest the taking down
of historical statues the event that
took place on lobby day
was to demonstrate in support of our
second amendment rights have no
connection whatsoever
but the left is so desperate to gin up
racial hatred
that they have to draw a a comparison
between completely unrelated events
so they go it could be like
charlottesville three years ago
security was tight as gun rights
advocates descended on richmond for
lobby day
to oppose legislation that would
restrict access to firearms in the state
the commonwealth braced for the
potential of extremist and white
nationalist groups
to disrupt the peaceful demonstrations
ralph northam declared a state of
emergency last week to ban
open and concealed firearms and other
weapons from the state capitol grounds
the crowd however
was peaceful with no immediate reports
of arrests or violence surprise
surprise the whole demonstration had
nothing
whatsoever to do with race and actually
one citizen journalist
approached one of the many black pro
second amendment demonstrators
and asked him if he was a white
supremacist we'll get to that in a
second
we will get to what this means for us
for the media and looking ahead into
2020 first though i've got to thank our
friends over at ring because you know
it's very very important
to feel safe that's what we're talking
about all day today
feeling safe in your life and your
liberty and in your property and making
sure your loved ones feel
safe one of the most important things
you can do right now to
make your self and your family feel safe
is to get ring that's what rings mission
is make neighborhoods safer
now you already know about their smart
video doorbells and motion activated
floodlight cameras
because i tell you about them all the
time because i really really like them i
so believe in ring
that i'm actually willing to give away
my ring devices
i'm going to give them away to friends
and family
as housewarming gifts they don't get
mine personally
but i i love this product so much i
always make it a gift because
i know that people are gonna feel safer
i'll give you an example i've told you
about my senior producer
who had these wackos show up to his door
in the middle of the night
and he was able to speak to them through
the phone and they chased him away i
also told you about my friends
who thought they had a burglar coming
around their house it turned out to be
just a cute little possum
regardless you just get peace of mind
whether you're in your home or at the
office or on a beach somewhere
on the other side of the world go get
ring
right now right now you can use my
code to grab a ring device for yourself
do it you hd video two-way audio
features on ring it's absolutely
tremendous go to ring.com right now
you will get a special offer on a
starter kit with video
doorbell and motion activated floodlight
camera the starter kit
has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around
your home ring.com knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
that is ring.com
knowles so the event in in virginia had
nothing
whatsoever to do with race and one
citizen journalist approaches one of the
black demonstrators there
and he asked him he said i heard all
these media reports that this was a
white supremacist
rally so are you sir a black man a white
supremacist here's his answer
are you a white supremacist yeah am i a
west i i was told there would be people
who
mean i got dreams oh wow you are you
really are blackface
like
[Laughter]
daddy we stay that's right brother yes
sir yeah daddy we staying
but they mad cause there wasn't no civil
unrest now they gonna be mad because
there wasn't no fighting
now they're gonna be mad cause then
nobody get locked up they gonna be mad
because
all the officers is at peace they gonna
be man cause ain't nobody out here
fighting they mad but guess what united
we stand
that's what this was about that's right
bro i'm from st louis and i ain't even
had to bring no weapon don't need no
weapon don't none of us need no weapon
but we got it
we got it we got em we got each other
back why
because united we stand that's what it's
about that's right
we straight bruh that's right white
black hispanic
latino mexican whatever united we stand
they're not gonna make this no communist
state they're not going to make us
no felons they're not going to turn off
law enforcement officers against us
just because y'all own some nonsense i
love this guy you know obviously he's
speaking very casually here but
there's a lot of insight in what he's
saying he's saying they're going to be
really mad
that there's not violence here they're
going to be really mad that there's not
division here they're going to be really
mad that there's not hatred here that's
what they've
been trying to gin up all week but
united we stand and what are we
standing united behind our constitution
our
shared culture our shared country
because we're all
all fellow countrymen here really
beautiful stuff i love he says
we don't even need weapons we don't need
them right here but we got them
and that's kind of the point we don't
need weapons i don't pack a gun every
place i go and i'm like armed to the
hilt all the time
no the reason that i don't feel that i
have to be is because we do have the
right to keep and bear arms the very
fact
that the individual in america has the
right to keep and bear arms
is a wonderful protection against
tyranny it's a wonderful protection of
our life
and our liberty and our property and the
loved ones around us
and because we have that right we don't
need to be so worried about it all the
time we just have to protect
that freedom the media were mad
they were mad they went mad not even
just in the sense that they were angry
they went mad in the sense that they
went insane nbc news reporter ben
collins
he ended up to his credit deleting a
completely baseless tweet
alleging that the demonstration was a
white supremacist rally here's what he
said
reporters covering tomorrow's white
nationalist rally in virginia
i'm absolutely begging you verify
information before you send it out
tomorrow even if it's a very sensational
rumor you heard from a cop
don't become a hero in neo-nazi
propaganda circles with made-up stuff
now i love this tweet this tweet to me
sums up the entire mainstream media
which is a sanctimonious
sort of advice to fellow americans and
in this case fellow elites
proving the point that he thinks he's
making and proving the point
with him as the butt of the joke he's
like i'm begging you
do not tweet out baseless information
and completely made up stuff tomorrow
at the neo-nazi hitler lover rally it's
like
buddy it's a second amendment rally you
did it you're the one
doing it not just him at least to his
credit ben collins deleted the tweet but
the whole rest of the mainstream media
did too another nbc news correspondent
gabe gutierrez
tweeted out a video of the rally and
and what he wrote with next to the video
was
chance of we will not comply
from gun rights protesters in richmond
so i said okay well fair enough i mean
if someone tries to take away my basic
constitutional rights
i certainly won't comply with that but
let's just see because i don't believe a
word that these people say anymore
let's just see what they're actually
chanting and i click the play button and
this is what i heard
see if you can make it out
oh
all right i didn't hear a whole lot of
we will not comply there
what i heard was the pledge of
allegiance but i'm not surprised that
the mainstream media couldn't recognize
the pledge of allegiance i assume they
haven't heard it and certainly haven't
said it in many many years that was the
tip of the iceberg okay
only the mainstream media were surprised
that the event yesterday went off very
well
because the mainstream media believed
that only nuts
own guns they think it's only lunatics
who own guns
but think about this in a standoff in a
peaceful demonstration
between people defending the
constitution
and lawless legislators trying to run
roughshod over people's basic civil
rights
which group do you think is more likely
to behave lawlessly
the ones defending the constitution were
the ones
trying to shred the constitution
obviously
the second amendment defenders are the
ones who are going to behave
according to the law they're the ones
who are going to behave appropriately
and it's going to be the lawless
legislators doesn't matter if they're
they were elected to office and they can
write laws they can behave lawlessly
often
more lawlessly than the rest of us
they're the ones who are going to try to
gin up
a bunch of division and tension so
what was the rally about just very
quickly we'll get through
what these guys were protesting because
the gun laws being proposed in virginia
are absolutely
absolutely terrible and unconstitutional
we'll get to that in a second first i
got to thank our friends over at rock
auto rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online
for 20 years go to rockauto.com right
now to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the thing i love about
rockauto
they got everything engine control
modules brake parts tail lamps motor oil
for me i don't know that much about cars
my car breaks down i don't know
anything about it and then you go to a
brick and mortar auto parts store
and they don't have the part they never
have the part they're too many parts
so what those guys do is they go online
and maybe they go to rock auto
and then they order the part and then
they charge you a huge markup you don't
need to do that
even for me i am not exactly an expert
when it comes to shopping for my car
i can navigate rock auto's website so
easily
you can figure out exactly what kind of
part you need for your car it's just
tremendous
the rockauto.com catalog is unique it's
easy to navigate
right now head on over to rock
rockauto.com
and when you get to the how do you hear
about us box make sure to fill
in knolls you can see all the parts
available for your car
and truck rockauto.com and most
importantly
most important of all pay close
attention write knowles k-w-l-e-s and
how did you hear about us box and then
we'll get credit for sending you over
there you're gonna love it it's a
wonderful family-owned business and they
will really help you out
with your car or truck okay
the gun laws in virginia are horrible
don't let anybody tell you
otherwise three bills passed the state
senate on thursday
one bill is to limit the number of guns
you can purchase
so you can only buy one handgun per
month now you might say who needs more
than one handgun per month i don't know
i can think of situations where you
would need to buy more than one handgun
within a month
but the question is why are we limiting
people's basic civil rights
maybe there's an argument to be made
okay maybe i haven't heard it yet but
maybe there is an argument to be made
however and this is the theme here
if you are going to take away somebody's
basic
fundamental constitutionally protected
civil rights
there needs to be a really really high
threshold in that argument and they they
have not made one in virginia
uh they want universal background checks
on gun sales this is really a way to
prevent people from passing guns along
to their kids
so who would who would object to
universal background checks
nobody the devil's in the details though
the question is am i not going to be
able to pass along my antique civil war
rifle to my
kids or something after i got it from my
father and him from his father and on
and on
no then there is a new rule
allowing localities to ban guns in some
public areas
again you can have that argument but the
right to keep and bear arms
is an individual right guaranteed by the
constitution
so if you're going to deprive people of
their fundamental civil rights you
better have a pretty good argument for
it
and those those that just pass the state
house
those are the most defensible of all of
them the rest of these regulations
are are draconian and outright
unconstitutional so one is a red flag
law
this would allow authorities to
temporarily take guns away
from anyone deemed by law enforcement to
be a danger to themselves or to others
now i don't have a problem with
depriving
certain people of rights that they would
otherwise be entitled to
if they pose a direct threat to
themselves or to others
however i am very strongly opposed
to taking away a person's basic civil
rights
in one case but not into others i think
that threshold needs to be very very
high
so for instance if you really believe
that somebody is an imminent threat to
themselves or to others
they got a couple of screws loose they
are a danger to society
okay that's fine
then you ought to be able to have that
person committed to an institution
then you ought to be able to deprive
that person of their voting rights then
you ought to be able to deprive that
person of their of certain legal rights
to control their own affairs
you ought to be able to apply the same
standard you're applying to the second
amendment
to all of the other civil rights because
i think very often what's going to
happen here
is law enforcement is going to say yeah
you're so you're a threat to yourself or
others so we're going to take away your
second amendment rights
i mean you're fine you can still vote
you can still live on your own you can
still drive a car you can still do
whatever you want but
just the gun the gun is going to be the
real issue well no of course not
if a person is is too
too much of a threat to have their basic
gun rights
included in the constitution then
certainly they shouldn't be able to
drive
driving is a privilege you apply to get
a driver's license from your state and
you don't have any right to a driver's
license
you do have a right to keep and bear
arms so again
i'm i'm fully admitting that certain
people
are not in full enough possession of
their faculties
to access all of their their rights this
would include children this would
include people
who are deranged this would include
people who are highly criminals
right there of course the people have
their rights deprived all the time
through their own actions or their
inability to control themselves
however the threshold has to be very
very
high another one is new rules about
reporting lost or stolen firearms again
this is a way just to take people's guns
away
increased penalties for recklessly
leaving loaded unsecured firearms near
children
yeah you shouldn't be able to leave
loaded unsecured firearms near children
certainly not
could that law be abused yeah probably
uh ban on anyone subject to a final
protective order from possessing
firearms and then
and then the ps resistance the one that
the left is always going for
a ban on assault rifles
now assault rifles have more or less
been banned in this country for decades
when people say assault rifles they're
referring to guns like the ar-15 the
most popular gun in america
which are not assault rifles in the
sense that they're not fully automatic
and that's the image that comes to mind
when people talk about it
but in another sense all firearms
are assault weapons they're all assault
weapons the point of a firearm is to
assault somebody they're not they're not
comforting i mean they're not there to
make you feel really pleasant
they're not there to massage your
temples when you've got a headache
they're there to shoot people
so yeah they they commit assaults now
obviously you want people who are
responsible who follow the law
who are good mature people to possess
firearms that's the premise of the
second amendment
but to say okay you can have all the
pleasant firearms that don't hurt
anybody but not the assault ones it's
completely disingenuous
the reason they use that euphemism is
simply to confuse people and the reason
they go after the ar-15
is it's pretty much the most popular gun
in america
they chose to do this on martin luther
king day
aoc was very upset that they chose
martin luther king day and we'll get to
how wrong she is in a second we'll get
to the dumbest conversation i've ever
listened to
the mainstream media shrieked that the
reason they chose martin luther king day
was because the the people protesting
were racist
bigots they hate black people
now actually the reason i chose it is
because there's this long-standing
tradition called lobby day in virginia
but the choice of or the the coincidence
of martin luther
king day is actually an important one
you know
martin luther king was a civil rights
activist
he was probably the most famous civil
rights activist in modern american
history
guns are a civil right the right to keep
and bear arms that is a basic civil
right protected
by our constitution listen to how
shocked aoc is doesn't know shocked the
leftist journalist ton heezy coats are
by the fact that this took place on
martin luther king day you know another
thing that i've been really thinking and
sitting with today
is that we there's this um gun rights
protest
that's happening down in richmond and
one mlk day
on mlk day yeah damn right it's on mlk
day
on him why do we celebrate mlk day we
celebrate mlk day
because of his work on civil rights and
so if you're going to have
a civil rights protest in america i
guess it makes a whole lot of sense to
do that
we will get to this extraordinarily dumb
speaking event between aoc
and don easy coats and then we will get
to impeachment because that's beginning
obviously today the impeachment trial in
the senate is starting today
then some great news for the pro-life
cause ahead of the march for life
first though i've got to talk to you
about the problem with your growing
business
all right the problem with growing
businesses very often and i've seen this
firsthand
because i've been involved in a lot of
startup businesses the daily wire
included
is very often they'll have a hodgepodge
of business systems right so they'll
start and they'll say okay
i know how to use this system for
accounting i am familiar with the system
for hr
i know about this system for sales so
we're going to have all these different
systems running but they don't know how
to talk to each other and so you can't
know your numbers
and let me tell you i have seen this
happen too many times
for comfort when people don't know their
numbers their businesses can run away
from them sometimes you're going to lose
your business
okay at the very least it's going to
take up too much time too many resources
that's going to hurt your bottom line
it's very important to know your numbers
that is where netsuite comes in netsuite
by oracle is the business management
software
that handles every aspect of your
business
in an easy-to-use cloud platform it
gives you the visibility and control
that you need to grow it saves time it
saves money it saves
unneeded headaches and right now
you can get a free guidebook
to help you understand your numbers
those are seven
key strategies it's a great guidebook
coming out from the number one
cloud business system head on over right
now
to netsuite by oracle
that is seven key strategies to grow
your profits at netsuite.com
knowles k-n-o-w l-e-s that's
netsuite.com
knowles download your free guide seven
key strategies to grow
your profits go check it out okay uh
we've got to say goodbye to facebook and
youtube
so don't go anywhere because we got a
lot more to get to the dumbest
conversation i've ever heard
from aoc then this whole impeachment
force
then some great news for the pro-life
cause and a whole lot
more than that and and by the way today
we're gonna be launching
uh a second show that i'll be having
over prageru called the book club the
first episode is out now
so go check that out at prageru march
for life is coming up
uh we're i'm in washington dc right now
that's why i'm not in my normal studio
the pro-life cause very very important
and while
pro-abortion activists are out there
shouting their abortions
and they're going on tv and referring to
pre-born babies as
parasites pro-lifers are fighting back
all of us at the daily wire have spoken
out in defense of life
last year at the march for life here in
washington dc
ben shapiro addressed a crowd of 100
000 people our advertisers were targeted
then as a result
of all of those actions by left-wing
political operatives
several advertisers pulled their ads
from our shows this is a constant battle
to protect the pro-life message from the
forces of abortion
another group that does this live action
live action has experienced the same
thing they're one of the most important
voices in the pro-life movement
they have helped to expose planned
parenthood and other abortion clinics
for the horrific crimes that they commit
on a daily basis
pro-abortion activists have targeted
live-action they've censored them on
social media platforms
and in some cases they've succeeded in
kicking them off altogether
that is why our daily wire.com members
are so important
your membership helps us say no to
advertisers who cave to left-wing
ideologies
you keep our pro-life message from being
canceled and from now until january 31st
a portion of any dailywire.com
membership will be donated to live
action
with promo code live action easy enough
to remember join dailywire.com
right now make your pro-life voice heard
dailywire.com we'll be right back with a
lot more
so i just listened to the dumbest
conversation i ever heard it was between
aoc
and the leftist journalist tony z coates
the reason i bring this to you
is not because i want to just slowly
kill each and every one of your brain
cells
it's because the conversation shows us
something one thing i love about aoc is
she shows you what the left
really is taken to its logical
conclusion it shows you the hypocrisy
and it shows you
just the utter emptiness of leftist
ideology so aoc begins
with the grand claim that people
shouldn't have a lot of money they
shouldn't have a billion dollars and
really
you can never make a billion dollars
because the only way that someone gets a
billion dollars is by
taking it from someone else why
specifically
does you know i'm
i'm joe billionaire i made widgets i
sold those widgets i made billions of
dollars you know
selling those widgets making those
widgets therefore those billions of
dollars are mine
why am i the enemy of health well you
didn't make those widgets did you
because you employed thousands of people
and paid them less than a living wage to
make those wishes for you
that's one of those statements like so
many leftist statements
that if you're not thinking at all
sounds like it means something but it
actually has no semantic content it has
no
meaning in the statement she said you
never make a billion dollars you
take a milli a billion dollars because
you hire people to do a job
but when you hire people to do a job
you're not taking from them you're not
stealing from them
it's actually the opposite you're giving
them your money
because you think that their skill their
service their labor is more valuable
than the money that you are giving them
and they think because they're engaging
in this free exchange
they think that the your money is more
valuable
than the labor that they are giving you
and so they exchange their labor for
your money
and everybody wins how do i know that
both sides feel this way
because both sides engage in the
transaction
here's another example i mean because
taken to the logical extreme which he's
saying is that
if you ever hire anybody to do a job
then you
aren't doing anything you're not
producing anything
let's say i write a book with words this
time okay i don't write a blank book i
write a real book
and let's say i would do a blank book
even okay it could be a blank book
i come up with the idea maybe i write a
little bit i i
come up i come up with the design and
then i
send that out and i hire a publisher to
print it
the publisher hires some tree company to
cut down the trees make the paper
the publisher hires some delivery people
to go deliver it to bookstores
then obviously the bookstores have the
money they have employees
the bookstores sell the books to
somebody else who needed a car to drive
there who who and you can see the
effects of this throughout the economy
my doing even a blank book will involve
so many people to make that book happen
and if i write a book with words then
you're going to have to hire people to
make the ink then you're going to have
to
i mean that's going to be a whole other
avenue of
of people who have helped to make that
happen does that mean i didn't write a
book
does that mean i didn't produce anything
no it means that i've worked together
with
other people in an economy in a society
to produce a product the employee who
does
the employee who's hired at the widget
company as tony heasy code says
did that employee make the i don't know
call it 50 grand a year
did they make 50 grand a year surely
they needed other people to make that
money they didn't come up with the idea
for the widget they didn't
build the structures of the business
they didn't
presumably there will be people down the
line of them
who they rely on to to make that job
happen
does anybody make anything no this is
the logical conclusion of barack obama
saying when he was president that you
didn't build that
you didn't build your own business which
was the basically the economic
motto of his presidency then aoc turns
it up a little bit more so she denies
that anybody can engage in an economy
voluntarily then she says that people
are literally
dying because of commerce
you made that money off the backs of
undocumented people
you made that money off of the backs of
black and brown people being paid
off a living wage under a living wage
you made that money off of the backs of
single mothers
and who all of these people who are
literally dying
because they can't afford to live
they're literally done
if they're literally at dying because
they can't afford to live then
presumably you're doing them a favor
you're saving them
by giving them a job right you're giving
them money
so you're saving them now what does aoc
know about my business does she know
that i'm
not paying people a living wage does she
know that i'm targeting
black and brown people and single
mothers and no of course not
she's just saying words she's just
making total grand assumptions about
other people's
businesses and she's
beginning with the premise that people
are entitled to other people's stuff
people are entitled to other people's
money do you know what the real minimum
wage is she's complaining about a living
wage
the real minimum wage is zero dollars
because
i don't owe you a job
and aoc doesn't really think that we owe
each other jobs you know why because
aoc then would have started a business
right aoc
would be just as on the hook as
everybody else's
has aoc ever created a single job in her
life of course not
how much does she give to charity i
don't know if i were a gamblin man
i'd guess probably less than jeff bezos
does
what has she done i mean the left is so
good at this the left does this all the
time
they're really good at criticizing
everybody else
pointing out the flaws and the
shortcomings of everybody else or
pointing out
how other people could do even more
which is always true you could always do
more
but they're never able to turn that lens
around on themselves analyze themselves
under the microscope
hold themselves to the same standards to
which they're holding other people
you know they criticize a guy like jeff
bezos super duper wealthy guy
because he's only giving a million
dollars at a clip to charity when was
the last time you gave a million dollars
to charity
was the last time aoc did anything for
anyone then she comes to the conclusion
of her argument no one ever makes a
billion dollars
you take a billion dollars
[Applause]
wow snaps snaps all around this is like
if i were in a freshman
slam poetry meet man i would really feel
feel the feels right now
aoc gets to her conclusion it it's just
as silly as her premise
but there is a little bit of honesty
right when she gets to the end
she's talking about taking she's talking
about an assertion of the will
then she gets to the heart of her
philosophy which is not
which is not based on principles it's
not based on any kind of coherent
argument
it's about power and she puts it in
exactly those terms
to be ethical if you're a billionaire
today
the thing that you need to do is give up
control and power
so i don't want your money as much as we
want your
power the people not me
[Music]
that's gonna get cut and clipped okay
obviously
she's a very confused young lady who
hasn't thought very much about
about important questions but there were
many contradictions in what she just
said
and yet she accidentally gave up her
whole point she said to be ethical
you need to give up control and power
and then in the very same breath she
said
we want your power so what she is
admitting here
is that her own system is unethical
right if if to be ethical you need to
give up power
and she wants power then she is
unethical but her system of politics
isn't based on ethics at all
it's not based on recent argument at all
it's just about
taking power it's just about
self-interest her system
presumes that the only way that i can
have more is if you have less
and that extends to the nature of
politics then she says
we watch but but i don't i'm not saying
we want the the power i'm saying the
people want the power
but not me even though i'm i guess i'm a
person and she's saying she's not a
person of course she's one of
the people but more specifically she's
the one who wants the power
she's not giving the power to some guy
who's working a low-wage job in the
middle of queens
she's taking it for herself through her
instrument of power which is
the state there are many more problems
with what she's saying because
she is not a systematic thinker let's
put it that way
but it suffices to leave it there this
is all about
power and and frankly that's what the
broader news story of this week and
probably
next week is as well which is president
trump's
impeachment trial nearly as dumb as
aoc's conversation with
tonighzy coates is the impeachment trial
of president trump which is kicking off
today he has been impeached the
president now
it is going to trial
there are all sorts of numbers going
around out there over
whether people want the president to be
removed or not uh i strongly suspect
that they do not want him to be removed
so
the republicans control the senate there
is no indication at all that any senate
republicans are going to turn on trump
so he is going to be acquitted he will
not be removed from office
this is the cost of a partisan
impeachment okay this
this impeachment unlike the others in
american history
was not a bipartisan impeachment there
were no republicans who voted to impeach
the president in the house there were
democrats who refused
to impeach the president so it was
bipartisan in terms of
letting him stay in office but it was
strictly partisan
in terms of the vote to remove him so
when you have a strictly partisan
impeachment guess what happens you're
gonna have a strictly partisan trial
especially when when they don't have any
uh legal basis for impeaching him
so the question that remains for this
trial is whether or not they're gonna
call witnesses now they already had
witnesses right you might say why would
they call more witnesses we just had
an investigation we just had testimony
we had the vote to impeach
so let's let's move on and do that okay
that is uh
that is what the american people seem to
want to do too most polls show
that the american people want to keep
the president in office until
a very convenient poll from cnn which
just came out right before the
impeachment trial
showed that 51 of americans want trump
removed from office
showed that 69 of americans want
witnesses called at the trial including
nearly half of republicans numbers are
obviously way off from every other poll
on the subject
but let's take them at face value okay
let's give cnn the benefit of the doubt
for no reason whatsoever
what do these numbers mean
i think what they mean is not what the
mainstream media thinks they mean the
mainstream media thinks it means that
the american people have finally turned
on trump
and we're going to kick him out and now
this way hillary hillary's going to be
president again
somehow and everyone's going to we're
going to live in a leftist utopia
something to that effect they what the
mainstream media think is this is
evidence of a public opinion change
and now people want trump out i think
what it means
is that nobody is paying attention
anymore
i think nobody's paying attention at all
they're not thinking through the
consequences it doesn't matter i don't
think anybody cares
so you get a question in a poll like hey
should there be witnesses at the
impeachment trial
and i i suspect people think yeah i
guess there are witnesses at a trial i
mean what is this about
yeah okay do that but when you get down
to brass tacks do we really believe that
the president ought to be removed
that he's committed some impeachable
offense i just don't see it
so what are the arguments for and
against democrats are desperate
for anything even remotely impeachable
that's why they want to call more
witnesses they didn't get it the first
time they didn't get it when it was in
the house so they're just saying please
if
we have 100 more witnesses maybe one of
them will give us something that's
impeachable
okay why would republicans want
witnesses well republicans want the
process to seem fair
and it just seems like witnesses should
be present at trials doesn't it
okay why does pelosi want it pelosi
wants to seem like she's giving her base
their money's worth before they
inevitably acquit the president
what about republicans maybe they want
witnesses because they want to drag out
this impeachment trial
because impeachment's been very good for
trump's approval numbers all right from
the beginning of impeachment until now
trump's numbers have gone up the
democrats have gone down plus you could
get hunter biden up there on the stand
and that would be
absolutely freaking hilarious because
that guy's a total degenerate and he
will expose more corruption
from his father however however what's
the argument against
witnesses this is politics okay it's
still politics
anything can happen in politics and i
think what the white house is
looking at now is they say it's like a
game of poker
they're up they're way up all right this
impeachment thing could not have worked
out better for them than it has
and i think what the white house and
maybe mitch mcconnell are thinking is
you got to know when to hold them
know when to fold them know when to walk
away know when to run
all right they maybe want to just cash
out their money say this has been a big
win let's take it and head into 2020.
moving on is the key here
because you know in in the 90s during
the clinton impeachment there was an
organization founded called moveon.org
it's one of the most prominent left-wing
organizations
and what people don't remember is that
moveon referred to the clinton
impeachment they said it's time to move
on
nobody cares anymore let's go let's
let's uh keep keep this going for the
american people
now everybody's changing their mind
right democrats who were against
clinton's impeachment are now for
trump's impeachment and vice versa for
republicans this is the problem with a
long career in politics eventually
you're going to look like a hypocrite
you don't need to but very often
you will how can you avoid that how can
you avoid the trouble that
that democrats and republicans are now
in avoid
sweeping abstractions and
generalizations about politics
admit that politics is politics there is
interest here okay it's just different
when it's your guy or the other guy
and we can all be honest about that and
at least then we're not being insincere
and have a little bit of a sense of
humor about it the media research center
again you know the guys who do news
busters
they dug up the mainstream media
reaction to the suggestion of calling
more witnesses
during bill clinton's impeachment trial
and you're going to be shocked to find
out
that it was a little different than
their reaction in the trump impeachment
the whole issue has been a sham it
shouldn't have gotten this far
the house acted improperly and passing
it on to the senate
why is your party dragging this thing
out why is this happening
why go through all this this business
about witnesses do we really need more
witnesses
it's going to add months to this thing
we should stop this this bogus inflated
case and get on with business of
governance
will these people just get down to
business and leave this impeachment
thing alone
it's going to be an enormous distraction
to the white house and all kinds of
issues that the congress ought to be
considering there's a long line
of the people's business that seems to
have been put aside
and apparently is going to be put aside
for weeks if not months now
we begin tonight with the voice of the
people the visitor who got up and
shouted
god almighty take the vote and get it
over with it goes on and on and on and
on
and on and on and you could listen to it
for another five years probably
and now they're all singing the opposite
tune so now it's republicans who want to
move on it's democrats
who want to stall i think in the
interest of both parties frankly
uh probably they should move on i think
it's hurting democrats numbers the
longer this drags out
and i think it's distracting republicans
and making us a little too complacent
about 2020 the longer we drag this out
and obviously president trump wants to
accomplish more of his agenda
so we've all made up our minds it's just
mindless screaming and a partisan
impeachment doesn't matter
anyway before we go i've got to talk
about some great news for the pro-life
cause really really great news ahead of
the march for life
it's great news in a scary nude story
scientists who have been researching the
question of
fetal pain like the pain that pre-born
babies feel
have concluded that it is no longer
likely that babies can't feel pain
before 24 weeks that was the former
consensus view
now they're saying that babies could
feel pain
possibly as early as 13 weeks
which is you know at that at that point
that's where a lot of abortions are
happening
we're you're almost cutting the amount
of time in half now
these are not activists these are not
pro-life activists these are just
british scientists
one of them is actually an abortion
supportive british pain expert
pro-choice
who used to think there was no chances
that that preborn babies could feel pain
that early
and now says that that assumption is
likely incorrect
and they've just written in the very
influential
journal of medical ethics that this new
evidence
is so compelling that to carry on with
abortions up until 24 weeks
despite that new evidence quote flirts
with moral
recklessness because of the pain
question
now it really shouldn't matter whether
preborn babies can feel pain or not who
cares
is the ability to feel pain now the
arbiter
of the value of life do you have dignity
in your life because you can feel pain
well what if you take an anesthetic what
if you uh
what if you put a take a couple
painkillers then is it moral for me to
kill you
no of course not feeling pain is just an
evidence
okay it's an evidence of the baby's
humanity which we already know because
it's a baby
whether or not someone can feel bane
should have no bearing whatsoever on
whether you're not
whether or not you're allowed to kill
that person
we make the argument for life logically
we make very strong philosophical
arguments to not kill babies like it's
unbelievable that we have to make these
arguments
it should be so obvious it should be
self-evident
all of the arguments are on the side of
life there is
no coherent philosophical argument
for killing babies now to the tune of a
million a year in this country
there is no argument the logic the
reason the facts
totally on the side of life
and yet the arguments are not enough one
must paint a picture that's the point of
the march for life the march for life is
not a
not a philosophical debate right it's
not not it's not a dry academic paper
and then there's a symposium and we all
read each other's papers
it's a demonstration to show
the support for the cause of life
because you need to show it the reason
that it matters that 13 week old
pre-born babies can feel pain
is because we have the image then in our
minds of this cute little baby
feeling pain while it's being ripped
apart by these psychos in the abortion
industry
that's the problem i mean that's what it
does to us it evokes so much more out of
us than just the arguments
going all the way back to the first
story today we can
have constitutional arguments over the
individual right to keep and bear arms
all day long
but part of the reason why we need to go
demonstrate is to show people what it
means
we need to we need to shoot down that
leftist narrative the leftist narrative
that people who want to keep their civil
rights are maniacs and bigots and
nuts and violent and chaotic and really
what do they do they show up they're
orderly they've got every single race
every color and shade of people there
and they behave very well there's no
violence and they clean up after
themselves
when they leave it's the same thing in
politics
it is not merely enough to make the
argument you certainly have to make the
argument that's the prerequisite
then you need to live it out all value
in this life is in flesh we got to put
it into our bodies
we have to put it into action and that's
what we saw this week in virginia that's
what we're going to see
this coming week for life here in
washington dc and it's going to be a
beautiful thing that's our show
come back tomorrow in the meantime i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
i'll see you then
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
director mike joyner executive producer
jeremy boring
senior producer jonathan hay supervising
producers mathis glover and robert
sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup jessua olvera production
assistants
mckenna waters and ryan love the michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. hey
everybody it's andrew clavin host of the
andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clinton
you